quoi non et maintenant
donner à la jeunesse l'envie de se
reconnecter avec la terre ou vert il y a
un an la ferme école graine d'avenir de
Magny-les-Hameaux vient de faire sa
première rentrée officielle cette
établissement propose une formation de
CAP primeur et un titre professionnel
d'ouvris horticole tous les jeunes âgés
de 14 à 20 ans peuvent-ils accéder sans
condition de niveau seul la motivation
compte on regarde nos élèves vers 3
métiers la production maraîchère bien
sûr la vente en direct de ces produits
tous les métiers de la chaîne de
distribution grossiste acheteurs
distributeurs primeurs bien sûr et enfin
tout ce qui touche à la restauration une
première année d'ouverture compliquée
par la pandémie de covid-19 et le manque
de notoriété de l'école c'est difficile
de trouver nos élèves il fallait aussi
que on fasse nos preuves on n'existait
pas donc une année passionnante mais qui
a demandé beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie
pour pouvoir être là aujourd'hui au
rendez-vous avec 12 élèves pour notre
première rentrée officielle à la ferme
après une scolarité difficile t on a
découvert graines d'avenir lors d'un
stage de 3e il a ensuite intégré la
formation de CAP primeurs entre cours
pratique et théoriques tout ce qui est
le conditionnement des légumes comment
les calibrer
qu'est-ce qu'un légume est vendable ou
pas on a eu on a aussi des cours avec
des professeurs qui viennent donc de
physique-chimie de mathématiques de
français d'histoire fin 2023 le célèbre
chef étoilé Thierry Marx ouvrira sa
propre école au sein de graines d'avenir
cuisine mode d'emploi permettra l'accès
à des formations de restauration
gratuite pour des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi on va s'installer avec une
structure et le matériel nécessaire un
chef des stagiaires bien entendu en
formation et nous allons utiliser que
les produits pour la protéine végétale
et que les produits du jardin des chefs
comme celui-là qui apprécient nos
légumes les utilisent dans leur cuisine
c'est le c'est la valeur du diplôme que
que nous prodiguons à nos jeunes
potimarron blettes ou encore betterave
de nombreuses variétés sont produites
sur la ferme si vous souhaitez déguster
ces produits biologiques sachez qu'une
vente directe est organisée chaque
mercredi de 10 heures à 18h